all right guys
bang bang i've got will here we're gonna
go over on chain metrics
every single saturday will what's going
on man
how much just taking it easy and
enjoying the hot weather oh how about
you paul
i'm doing well buddy all right let's get
into it bitcoin seems to be just
ranging uh still but it looks like
there's a whole bunch of stuff you've
been able to take out of the on-chain
metrics for this week so
uh where do you want to start yes i
guess we could just kind of start with
the price action
um i think we had kind of a funny week
where we we just kept ranging sideways
you know last week we had talked about
how we were just
kind of sitting in this range between 32
and 40 k
um and we had kind of drawn this this
triangle pattern
um which i saw a lot of other traders on
twitter
we're looking at as well and i bring
this up because
we finally had a breakdown out of that
which was funny because you you'd expect
that would break down
um but immediately you saw a reversal so
bitcoin did the complete opposite of of
what everybody expected it to do but
nonetheless we had kind of a sweep down
to range lows around
31k and then we've had kind of this
sharp rebound into today where we're
sitting around 37k
so price action wise we did get a strong
bounce off of the off of those range
lows
um so that's a good thing and then
another like non-on-chain thing
i think it's it's interesting to watch
how uh bitcoin's been reacting a little
bit differently to to news
i think for a while you you had you know
bad news in price with tank
good news it wouldn't really do anything
now you have
you know good news is is uh seemingly
pushing price up and bad news isn't
doing as much damage so
i think just kind of from like a
fundamental analysis standpoint
like that that's something that i've
noticed that has changed over the last
week
um but you know overall i think
what what you know i was really trying
to get at in the newsletter this week is
that we're kind of in this
re-accumulation process
we had talked about you know we're kind
of consolidating and it's going to take
a while
after we had that original dump it was
going to take a while for
you know those that loose supply to kind
of find a new home
but i think this week you're starting to
see some of that
supply move into accumulation
and and so we can we can kind of get
into the the different metrics but
that's kind of like the high level of it
got it let's start with super maybe
remind us what soaper is and then what
you saw
uh this week there yeah sober something
that we've touched on almost every week
i feel like um
it's it's pretty much the net profit of
the coins that are trading on
any given day um when when you have a
the ratio is over one that means that
the coins are trading at profit
under one means that they're they're
trading at a loss and so
um for anybody looking at the newsletter
and then i think we'll have the charts
in this video
you can see um we we had this big
drawdown in sober
um and it was the largest drawdown since
march of last year
which off the bat is good because you
have this big reset of profit taking
but then we have another drawdown um
with i think it was like two days ago
and so that's showing that what it looks
like to be a double bottom
um and kind of a higher low which is
something good to look for
um and then also you have a higher low
in the in the oscillator while you have
a lower low in price so um like a lot of
technical analysts will
will recognize this is this is a bullish
divergence so you have you know higher
higher low in the in the in the
oscillator and then a lower low in price
and a bearish divergence would be you
know higher high in price
lower low in the oscillator but so we
have that we're back over the one
threshold
and then um and then also just making
making that higher low double bottom
soaker looks pretty good i would like to
see it stabilize above one though
and then possibly if we had a big
drawdown to see one
kind of serve as uh as support um
throughout the bull market one usually
serves other than major corrections
usually serves as that
um that bounce threshold because
you know in a raging bull market people
aren't going to really want to sell at a
loss
so you really need a big swing in
momentum like what we've seen over the
last few weeks to get people to
to start to sell out a loss but
throughout the bull market and and most
of the corrections we had had
um sober had bounced off one so to see
us kind of consolidate above one and
then if we had a big
downswing for for that that threshold to
that one threshold to service
uh as support that would be that'd be
really bullish in my eyes but
so far sober looks pretty good got it
and then there's this really interesting
relationship between short-term holders
and long-term holders that uh that
you've identified maybe explain that a
little bit
yeah so this has been another trend that
we've been keeping an eye on
but for a while we had been saying that
the short-term holders were out
selling the long-term holders so if you
look at like
a month's change short-term holders have
moved 422 thousand
roughly btc out of their holdings while
long-term holders have added 389
000 so you get this net difference of um
shorter term holders
selling um 32 000 like if you do the net
between the two right
but over the last seven days that's
that's kind of reversed
so over the last seven days long-term
holders have accumulated
a little over 31 000 more btc than
short-term holders
so i think that's a good sign you're
seeing um you know
the short-term holders uh the ones that
we're gonna sell at a loss have now sold
at a loss
and you're also seeing um this this
offset of longer-term holders now buying
at a higher rate of
of the shorter term holders that either
are getting you know
exhausted or they're running out of
supply to sell but you know
that that's showing to me consolidation
because you have
um you know this this uh these
contrary forces where the short-term
holders are
um had been selling really hard but now
the longer term holders have kind of
edged them out and you're now seeing
that that net positive between the two
in favor of the long-term holders so
that's something that
um that shows me that perhaps that this
reaccumulation process is towards the
like the later stages um i
a few weeks ago i would have i would
have said maybe it's going to be a month
or two but
um the long-term holders are really
aggressively um adding to their
positions here
and you know especially over the last
week week and a half two weeks
they've really been outpacing that up
the short term so i perhaps that means
that that we won't have
as long of an accumulation as as i had
originally kind of thought
yeah i think my main takeaway from a lot
of your analysis is definitely the
re-accumulation phase is getting close
to uh to being over before we move up
again um one of the other things you
identified was this illiquid supply
change
uh maybe describe that a little bit and
kind of what you're seeing
yeah so um gladstone has this metric and
it it basically looks at different
addresses and then clusters them into
entities
and then looks at the the selling
behavior of that entity
so first of all they have to hit a third
a certain age threshold which is a 155
days which is
by the way for anyone who's wondering
the same threshold for
the long and short-term holders so over
over 155 days and then i have to have a
very
low i forget what the what the
percentage is but
statistically like very low um selling
behavior
and then they're determined a liquid
liquid is like you know coins that are
being moved in and out all day long
so throughout the bull market one of the
you know kind of one of the big
narratives i guess you could say was a
um
the coins moving off off exchanges and
then b
um from like an on chain between like
the on-chain community i guess
um this illiquid supply thing where rick
um willy woo was calling it the rick
astley chart because
uh these holders look like they were
never gonna let us down but they did let
us down
in uh late late may to early june
but uh that that now seems to be
reversing back in
into what looks like accumulation so
that's something to keep an eye on
um seeing it and once again that's in
the newsletter but seeing that flip back
green
in my opinion would would be really
bullish because
you're you're starting to see um the the
supply becoming liquid that that weaning
off and more coins are moving into
strong hands
but for now i mean we're not out of the
woods um
it's not like screaming bullish or
anything but it's something to
if it continues this trend it's a good
sign
hey guys what's going on before we
continue with this awesome episode i
want to quickly talk about our sponsor
kraken
for the last 10 years kraken has built
one of the best platforms to buy and
sell cryptocurrencies online
they've got a brand new mobile app the
kraken app today you can go on and buy
bitcoin
or up to 60 of the most popular
cryptocurrencies in the world
and you can do that on the go 24 7.
all you have to do is simply download
the app connect your bank account
and you can get started investing with
as little as 10
it only takes a minute to get started
with the new kraken app you'll have your
portfolio
in your pocket you can track your
portfolio see who the winners and losers
are every day
track your favorite project or just
simply look at the trading volume for
your favorite assets
it has all the features you need without
any of the complexity
it's simply the best place to buy and
sell cryptocurrencies
so go to kraken.com bang bang to learn
more
or go to your favorite app store and
simply search the word kraken and you
can download the mobile app there
kraken's been a longtime supporter of
this show so to say thanks it would mean
the world to me if you would go and
download their new mobile app
all right let's get back into this
episode i hope you're enjoying this one
absolutely uh what about futures open
interest
or or short positions on the various
exchanges
yeah so futures open interest had pretty
much been flat since we had had that big
drop on that you know
wednesday down to 30k but over you know
it was funny when we when we broke and
maybe this was just timing but
when we broke that triangle which was i
think the pattern a lot of people were
looking at to be honest
um we had kind of the spike in in open
interest
and then when it when it snapped back up
i think what had happened was
um a lot of people had loaded up on the
bottom of that range when we broke
out to the to the downside and people
loaded on shorts
um because people were like oh this
thing broke out everybody's everybody's
looking at the same pattern so we're
gonna go way lower
and so what happened was we had this
this drop and then
just kind of uh rapid you know
nasty wick back up and then we headed we
headed back in the other direction and
and
it was almost like bitcoin has this
tendency to go in the direction that's
going to
liquidate the most people and that's
definitely what happened here
because everybody it seems like took
that one side of the trade you saw
funding like drop off a cliff
um and then all of a sudden you had this
big reversal
but right now when you know one
interesting thing
uh just on that same note is yeah the
there's been a big spike in shorts
throughout the week um coming from
bitfinex
which i the only other time that i've
seen anything like this like recently
was the day before we had that big drop
um on that wednesday so
there's a big increase on on the seventh
and like midway through the ninth
so either i don't you know obviously
there's no way to know
um this could just be someone hedging
but if if
this is you know perhaps someone in
disbelief we could be setting up for a
short squeeze um
but that's just something to keep in
mind either either somebody knows
something or or
they're getting ready to get wrecked
yeah it could
be both who knows uh what what are the
miners doing
yeah the miners is an interesting one
because you know for a while we had been
talking about oh
miners are stacking miners are stacking
but what we've actually seen over the
last week
um actually the day after we dropped the
last episode uh miners
miners started selling um and especially
from china
so you know glass node they can they
can't recognize every miner but they can
kind of like look at look at the main
ones
it looks like um some of the transverse
through exchanges have come from from
the chinese miners specifically
and then obviously just a big spike in
what they call other it's basically like
all these entities they know are miners
but they can't label them
so there's a big spike in that who knows
what what percentage of that were
chinese but just in
the main ones that glass node is is able
to track
um it a lot of that selling does look
like it's coming from china especially
from one
uh one pool called pulin which is
uh the second largest i'm not super
familiar with mining
um but i looked it up and said pool in
is the second largest uh
pool in china so you know it's not it's
not like they're
dumping all their supply and it's
something like that would
have some crazy effect on price um you
know they're i'm talking like 5000 btc
um nothing nothing crazy that that's
gonna you know significantly move the
price but
um it is interesting to just watch you
know we have all that stuff
um china's coming out saying they're
banning mining and it does look like
um you know we've had this drop off in
hash rate
but also some some selling or perhaps
just um
you know maybe maybe these maybe these
miners are just
relocating and they they need to you
know they need some capital to to move
over or
maybe they just want to you know move
around their holdings while they while
they change locations who knows but
i do see that that interesting um
movement of coins out of
uh the miners wallets while we've had
all this you know this this china flood
about china spain and bitcoin et cetera
yeah there's some political and kind of
regulatory things that are going on that
could be causing uh things that would be
abnormal on the on-chain metrics mainly
be just because they have to move they
have to
get access to cash uh so it makes a ton
of sense the last metric that i want to
look at or kind of last analysis
is plan b stock to flow i think this
infamous analysis at this point uh
there's a lot of people who think it's
accurate there's a lot of people who
don't think it's accurate where do we
stand is it still valid or
or has it been invalidated yeah um
shout out to plan b really good dude um
his model is is something that i i kind
of think is um
directionally correct it's something
where you can you can look at to kind of
gauge the broader cycle
um i wouldn't i wouldn't perceive trade
the stock to flow
price and use that as some kind of
short-term
um it seems like he was he was posting
that some traders are actually using the
stock to flow multiple that to trade off
of but
um i see it as more kind of a broader
cycle uh you know something you look at
to gauge that but that's just my opinion
we are currently having this the second
largest uh or actually i'm sorry to the
downside the largest
um deflection in in the history of the
model so
it's something to keep an eye on i think
we're i saw he posted something we're
sitting on like the very lower bound he
has
the main the main um stock to flow you
know the model price and then he has
these two
bands around that and we're sitting him
right on that lower band so
it's it's crunch time for for s2f and
and we'll see over the next couple weeks
uh but this bounce is looking a little
promising for plan b
so basically if it goes lower there's a
potential that it gets invalidated but
it looks like just based on
some of the recent uh kind of more
bullish activity uh
if the price recovers then we'll still
be intact there bounce right off the
bottom as you would expect it to
uh and kind of still bull market ready
to roll
yeah yeah um i think that that's what
plan b is definitely hoping for
i think that's what we're all hoping for
too but uh we'll see what happens over
the next few weeks
absolutely and so it seems like uh this
week the big theme is just that the
reaccumulation phase uh is nearing an
end right which means
uh you know there was a ton of
volatility there was fear
there was greed all this stuff that
played out uh but we've been going
sideways for a little bit and people
have been re-accumulating strong hints
have been buying more and more
uh and at some point here uh that's
gonna end in the short term
uh with likely but you know can't
promise but likely a move upwards is
that fair to kind of categorize the
analysis
yeah i think so and and um
only thing i would say is that about the
volatility i think the volatility like
as we as we turn through the channel has
been trending down
but once once we break out of that of
the of the
whatever consolidation pattern you want
to call it um whether it's just like a
horizontal range that we're in
um once we finally get a strong move i
think that volatility comes back because
the futures comes back
and this is something i should have for
us next week but i'm trying to put a
ratio of
the futures open interest to the market
cap to kind of engage
when the future's open interest has a
stronger effect on
on you know on price and then therefore
it would be more important to look at
things like funding rates
etc but um yeah i think i think if you
if you have a strong move and that's
what we kind of saw today in that tick
up and
not today um yesterday and that tick up
and futures open interest
i think it's showing like when we have a
strong move you're gonna see
traders come back in um but while we're
in the range people are
people are still waiting uh but but
other than that yeah i i completely
agree
awesome man well listen thank you so
much for uh for taking time to do this
uh if anyone has not yet subscribed to
will's email
uh where can they go do that will yeah
sure so we're
doing these episodes every week and then
i have a newsletter uh it's
btc by wc3
dot sub stack dot com and it's it's free
all you have to do is just type in your
email and hit subscribe
you're grown a big audience over there
pretty quickly i i think you're
you may be onto something here so uh
keep up the great work and uh everyone
here on youtube you'll see us again uh
uh on next saturday appreciate it pop
take it easy
all right everybody